- The only thing I hated
getting on Halloween
was peppermints from old people.
- (beep) peppermints from old people.
But I love old people.
(slow music box music)
(creepy music)
- We just went ghost hunting,
so all I feel right now is like this.
- I hate that my back is to an open room
that had a lot of activity in it earlier.
(snake hissing)
- Filled Twizzlers.
(growl)
- Twizzlers is moving
into the Cow Tales game.
- Are you a Twizzler or a Red Vine person?
- I'm-
- Caramel apple to Halloween.
- They nailed it.
- It's like celery with
peanut butter pouring out.
- It tastes like adventure, and fun.
- Like a Starburst?
- The caramel actually makes
the Twizzler really good.
- And it's low fat.
- It confuses me.
- I would have this
over regular Twizzlers.
- Pumpkin spice M&M's.
(growls)
- If one of the M&M's worked at Starbucks,
it would be this one.
- It's an interesting
flavor, I'll give it that.
It gives a new dynamic to the M&M.
- It tastes kind of like weed.
- Weed with dish soap.
- It's what people that like candy
eat to feel sophisticated.
- This could be potentially
a gateway candy.
(scream)
- [female] Pecan pie flavor.
- I wouldn't mind this
with like a cup of tea.
- That is straight up offensive.
- I want another one.
- This actually-
- [male] No.
- [female] tastes like pecan pie.
It's really good.
- I actually hate this.
- I wouldn't mind this ice cold.
- Ice cold (laughs).
- Any adult who eats candy corn, I'm like.
(horn)
- It tastes like caramel to me.
- Better than regular candy corn.
- This is dentist candy.
- It tastes like white chocolate.
I like white chocolate.
- You taste candy corn?
- No.
- If I were watching a crappy movie,
and I had a bowl of these,
I'd eat them all.
- [male] 3 Muske-fears.
- 3 Musketeers have
really good commercials
where they break-
The inside's red.
- It's supposed to be blood.
- If this is what blood
tastes like, then I'm in.
- Dude I swear to God I
(beep) hear something.
- Is it strawberry in the middle?
- Maybe a little bit of a cherry in there.
- Yeah, doesn't taste different,
just has food coloring in it.
- Nougat means rich,
creamy, frothy filling.
- I thought that nougat is what you call
you're little friend that
tags along with your group
when you go trick-or-treating.
Like that one's a little nougat.
(door clanging shut)
- [male] Oh, boogers. Box of Boogers.
- [female] Box of Boogers.
- Tangy boogies that look and feel real.
- Snot your regular gummy.
Like snot.
- None of them are brown.
I've never found a
green booger in my life.
- This is like post-cold boogers.
- They're very hard on the inside.
- You got to work at it.
- Yeah.
- Like a real booger.
- Got better with a few chews.
- It's not a real booger texture.
A booger you can chew
through much more easily.
(both laugh)
- So you've had experience
chewing boogers.
- Sure I have.
I was a kid once.
And an adult.
- This super awesome atmosphere
made the candy taste better,
and knowing that there's
probably some ghost
standing here wanting to eat it.
- Get creative with candies.
Candies are fun.
Why shouldn't we try more?
Being creeped out
while you're getting your
tongue creeped out, too,
is a lot of fun.
(mumbles)
- (beep) stop it. (laughs)
- That was bad.
- I want to get out of here.
(wolf howling and crickets chirping)